[Music]
i was just thinking of one practical
thing we could do
that
that your listeners might like which is
can i just tell you the three questions
that you can ask to measure your urgent
optimism and give you a sense of which
of those three habits or skills you
might want to practice more so it's
really simple and i i'd say you can pick
this for any topic so it might be the
future of psychedelics for mental health
treatment might be something you're
interested in or could be the future of
college education to pick a specific
topic and then you ask three questions
when you think about the next 10 years
how much do you think
this topic will change
on a scale of one to ten so one is
almost no change everything stays the
same ten is
extreme change almost everything is
dramatically rethought or reinvented
right so on a scale of 1 to 10 how much
change do you expect 1 to 10
on a scale of 1 to 10
when you think about the changes that
are likely to happen in the next 10
years
are you mostly worried or mostly excited
about them so one is extremely worried
ten's extremely excited
and then one to ten
how much influence or control do you
have personally
in how this change happens
and so one is almost no controller
influence and 10 is almost complete
control or influence and and and not
only is it helpful for us to think like
oh i need to practice some more
realistic hope find some reasons to hope
if i have a low number or i need to pay
more attention to the world economic
forums global risk report if i'm like
out of 10 maybe i should try to learn
more about the risks
it's so cool to share numbers with
people
and man do i love talking to people who
are at like
sevens eights on nines on topics that
i'm at it one two or three about
is super fun so i just wanted to put
that it's like a practical fun for you
talk to people about it share your
numbers and think about how you might
practically increase your urgent
optimism on on the ones that you have
lower numbers for could you give a
personal example for yourself on
a
particular topic industry
situation that we haven't discussed yet
it could be one that we've talked about
if if that lends itself
but
that would be super helpful for me
because when i hear these questions
i i can see the value in answering them
and
i find that my default so i'm not asking
for a solution to my particular
malfunction here but i think it
correlates very highly to the kind of
existential malaise and apathy of a lot
of young people although i'm definitely
too bearded and too bald to be
considering myself young at this point
nonetheless though
i can answer question one pretty easily
for most things and then i think
generally i skew very pessimistic yeah
i have a very hobby in view of humans in
general which is maybe another issue and
then three with respect to like the
agency
sometimes i feel very little agency or i
feel a lot of agency but i don't know if
i want to be
just like going through
just a forest of headaches and
difficult humans with a machete for most
of my time yeah if the upside isn't
certain so could you give an example of
something uh
in your life that that you've sort of uh
applied these questions to
let's go back to drones so
drones create a lot of anxiety in people
for a good reason they create noise
pollution they create visual pollution
they can be used for surveillance remote
policing privacy intrusions
warfare warfare right and i started
seeing drones just out in the world
seeing signs like no drone zone i didn't
know is that a law is that a
recommendation i realized i didn't know
what the rules or policies were around
drones i didn't know why why are we
spending so much time and money
developing this technology all i ever
hear about are
you know a lot of the risks so for me
drone was a space that i wanted to
explore and maybe build some urgent
optimism and not optimism in the sense
of i'm going to become an evangelist for
drones and i'm going to be like the
future is great i don't have to worry
about it anymore but to increase my
confidence that i can imagine a future
with more drones i understand what it
might means the risks the opportunities
and that there are things i can do to be
ready for it or help shape it so i
started talking to people
looking on google scholar finding drone
hobbyist communities what are people
using them for that is not terrible
right so i learnedaboutwitness.org
actually has a drone training program
for people to
document war crimes human rights
violations authoritarian governments
doing terrible things to create
irrefutable evidence right so to be a
witness for this
as drones as a form of activist
journalism and documenting reality
i learned about the emotions that we
feel
when we look at aerial footage so drones
it turns out can create a kind of
visceral
feeling that i don't even know if we
have a word for it yet it's a strange
new positive emotion
where we have an almost this kind of
god-like omniscience because we're we're
seeing everything from above we're
moving we're like swooping through the
air like again eagle there's an
incredible new positive emotion that we
don't even have a word for yet that
artists can use storytellers can use
therapists can use by
using drones to
to give us a viewpoint we've never seen
did you wanna yeah i was just gonna say
my my ask of my audience is somebody
come up with a clever german word for
whatever that
and put it online because there's
there's got to be
some way to slap a bunch of adjectives
and nouns together into it
thank you tim that is that is an amazing
suggestion
what else did i learn i i went to google
news and was like just show me what
people are doing with drones right now
and i learned that
just a couple of months ago the first
organ was delivered for a for transplant
that they couldn't get this organ i
think it was a heart they couldn't get
it there fast enough except for
delivering it by drone so the first
emergency medical delivery so learning
about the positive uses
while also learning about you know well
what are what are the rules and policies
like who decides i mean to me this it
became fascinating rather than anxiety
producing to expose myself to
who is in charge of drones is it the faa
yes in part is it local parks and
recreation yes in part because in order
to have future power we have to know
who's making the rules right because i
need to know what the rules are who's
shaping them who's advocating for what
it's like building urgent optimism it's
like following a string out of a
labyrinth it's like you're taking all
these twists and turns you're you've got
your radar up so you're going to hear
about weird new risks you're going to
hear about cool new uses and i like to
think it's just like it's essentially a
process of opening your mind and if
there's something you care about
this these habits of looking for the
clues and
if you're negative looking for well
who's excited and what are they excited
about to kind of create the balance
who's in charge who's who has power now
so you can even understand where power
is being concentrated what are the
companies that are most advanced in this
technology it's literally just a
practice it's a practice like meditation
where we just have to kind of show up
with this curiosity actively
collecting these clues
every day
you